les gens viennent pour regarder le match
un supporter et pour paris en fait y'a
vraiment l'affluence pendant la crue
pendant les matches de la can
[Musique]
je ne rate pas les matches de la can
parce que je suis déjà passionné du foot
j'aime le foot et voilà donc chaque fois
qu'il ya match a pas sillage des
problèmes de sous je rate pas je parie
toujours que je sélectionne mes matches
je prends les matches les plus fiables
je leur ai annoncé les comptes à travers
internet je me suis les matches en cours
parce que
j'aimerais avoir mon cash demain matin
parce que quand vous me disais quand
vous misez sur les mâts dujon en vo paye
le lendemain
[Musique]
je à la partie face à sion le foot que
dans nos traditions
autrefois
en temps normal nous pouvons enregistrer
20 à 30 clients lorsque le cameroun joue
on peut enregistrer au minimum 50
clients 50 clients qui viennent jouer
uniquement pour le cameroun
[Musique]
je joue en promotion 2 mai - viège s'est
mis fin je veux tu ne peux jouer me
francs si j'ai cinq enfants je vous dis
mis fin depuis 18 ans j'ai beaucoup
gagné de bruijn le cameroun et son
primat son deuxième match m'a fait
gagner 10 juillet musique 2006 ce match
préoccupé 30000
la plupart des matelas quand j'ai parlé
là dessus
les matériaux par mu costa de regarder
le match
la côte d'ivoire doit gérer et à fort
myer parler et parler pour l'algérie
malgré les mêmes pays
[Musique]